hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my Gotham episode 18 video and
just a quick heads up there aren't gonna
be any new episodes until Monday April
13th May because March Madness they
didn't really explain why but there's
just gonna be a break just like arrow in
the flash don't worry there's still
plenty of Batman stuff we can talk about
while it's a way feel free to leave any
requests for bonus videos so let's get
going just careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet
starting with top five moments number
five alfred is going to go after his old
friend it seemed like they were teasing
that bruce was gonna track him down it
with Catwoman's help but if anyone's
gonna punch him in the face I think it's
gonna be Alfred it's like the show has
given each main character an opponent to
take down before the end of the season I
think Bruce's take down will be someone
on the board
it'll be like Batman Begins when Bruce
Wayne took down Rutger Hauer character
like the evil board member it'll be kind
of like that there's no way they would
deny Alfred punching his old friend in
the face his loyalty seems a little
weird like he's not gonna rat him out
but he stabbed him so maybe we'll find
out that the board coerced his friend
into doing that to him but I think that
Alfred is definitely gonna choke him out
it just feels like a wasted opportunity
to not let Alfred get some more parkour
badass moments moving on to number four
everyone has a Cobblepot did anybody
have that Peter Griffin moment when
Bullock said that it's like he said the
name of the thing he said the title of
the episode I always laugh when I see
moments like that but the cobblepot's
are just everyone's dirty laundry it's
just the dirt that Loeb has on everyone
in the GCPD they didn't say who
Bullock's person was that he killed just
it sounded like some low-level crook
that some mob boss wanted to get rid of
but I loved Gordon and two-face going on
the hunt even that exterior shot of the
diner they just looked so beautiful just
from a visual sense dent didn't get too
crazy in this episode which was kind of
a bummer because I think he's a lot more
fun when he's being crazy like crazy to
face mode but even though they didn't
swing too ridiculous funny I felt like
there were a lot of funny dark moments
like whenever they smash cut from the
back of Bullock's car to them holding
Globes old partners head while they were
driving around it looks like chill dudes
I got this I know how to interrogate
people those are some of my favorite
funny moments it's not necessarily meant
to be a comedy moment but they use the
action for comedy I think the show is
finally figuring itself out a little bit
the pacing the jokes the dialogue all
worked so much better it also helps that
they're like nearing the end of the
season so it's like they're ramping up
for their big WTF finale
speaking of which number three meet the
newest Big Bad the dollmaker I explained
in last week's episode this dollmaker is
slightly different from the dollmaker of
the comics and like the Barton Mathis
dollmaker that we saw on arrow that's
the most recent comic book dollmaker or
the one that's best known I'm interested
to see if they weave him into the story
the same way that the comic book
dollmaker interacts with Batman Joker
and the other villains of Gotham as of
now it seems like he has more of a
connection to the mob with his business
of replacing the organs of really rich
people giving them whatever surgery they
want that WTF revealed what Geoffrey
comes though that was his comic book II
as you could get in this episode that's
what the dollmaker the comics really
does combining a bunch of different body
parts I'll say that the actor playing
him is done a pretty good job so far
he's been pretty reserved I think the
last thing I remember seeing him in was
that Vin Diesel Chronicles of Riddick
movie he played a big villain in that so
I think that's why they cast him in this
role because they want dollmaker on this
show to be a big villain I'm not gonna
call him the big bad this season yet
just because it seems like Gotham is
positioning a couple different people in
this rogues gallery and until Gordon
took care of Loeb at the end of the
episode I kind of thought that he was
gonna be one of the big bads too but now
it seems like he's in Gordon's pocket
speaking of being in people's pockets
number two Gordon makes a deal with the
penguin I love the way that they brought
this back around with Bullock's comment
he reminds Gordon that no matter how
many good things he does it's not gonna
outweigh the one bad thing he did I
think the one bad thing that he was
referring to was gonna be whatever
favored penguin asks of Gordon his
no-questions-asked favor
penguin also asked for access to the
files since they didn't find any I'm not
sure that he saw them so as the scales
will wait right now Gordon just owes
penguin that favor penguin doesn't have
info on a bunch of other people yet
although because those files exist I do
think that someone's gonna search for
them in the future I think they'll be of
use as penguin said like whenever he
mentioned Falcone's favorite liquor in
Gordon it's like why the hell would I
care about that that knowledge might
come in useful someday so just set a
bookmark on the commissioners files
because if someone can get their hands
on those in the future then they could
probably take down most of the big
people in the city that just sounds like
something
penguin would want to get his hands on
maybe with the help of the Riddler I
don't know if we're gonna get a Riddler
penguin team up in season 1 just because
the Riddler has not broke bad yet but
that just ditches awesome season 2
Riddler Breaking Bad and of course my
number one WTF moment meat lobes
daughter Miriam totally crazy
this is a really fun Easter Egg so the
actors playing Miriam actually did the
voice for Supergirl during the animated
Justice League cartoon I laughed so hard
when she made the joke about crushing
little bird skulls and then told penguin
you look kind of like a bird it's like
she was gonna reach out and just squish
him like a bug it was just such a great
moment just in general there were so
many of these amazing creepy moments
like whenever they sat down to dinner
with the two caretakers always beware of
creepy houses in the middle of nowhere
with people that seemed way too nice
they call it the farm which actually
kind of reminded me of a Battlestar
Galactica episode involved involving a
lot of like baby harvesting the title of
that episode was the farm and then the
house also kind of reminded me of Norman
Bates's house from psycho I've said it a
whole bunch of times but one of the
things that Gotham does really really
well is set design even like there's CG
outdoor scenes like the diner scene that
I talked about then you have places look
at the doll makers office like the
inside of his office just looked amazing
so just in general the show has gotten a
lot better I mean I think it's figured
itself out a little bit more it's
figured the characters out found their
voices but it's set design has always
been solid here's my big question for
you guys right now do you feel like the
doll maker is going to turn out to be
the big bad are you expecting someone
else like someone from the Wayne board
to be even worse I know I didn't mention
him but we have to talk about the
Riddler - the Riddler versus this guy
here the actor that plays The Riddler
quarry Michael Smith was talking about
his reaction to this moment
he said that we would see the rage on
the Riddler's face at being riddled
himself like yes he enjoys riddles but
he hates it when people throw riddles in
his face the really cool thing about the
riddle though is that he was talking
about a clock I feel like that's an
allusion to a ticking clock a countdown
clock to the Riddler Breaking Bad I'd be
really interested to see if when he
actually does something evil it'll be as
part of this Miss Kringle storyline or
if it'll be something totally random yes
so the Kringle stuff is making him
really pissed off so he could try to
take this cop down but it could also be
a situation where
an opportunity presents itself for him
to vent vent his rage and it just ends
up being some random other thing it's
always funny to see like the big Batman
villain triggers like what is it that
triggers them to do something crazy I
feel like the penguin is already there
he took down Margie with a shotgun no
problem at the end of the episode so of
all the crazy villains on the show he is
the one that is least off the rails I
feel like the Riddler is gonna be the
one that's really gonna go off the rails
so I already mentioned most of the
Easter eggs in the episode and I already
spent most of last week's episode
explained the dollmaker character about
how he's tied up with the Joker's origin
story in the new 52 but if you guys saw
anything else just write it in the
comments below
just a reminder no new episode till
April 13th so for the next four weeks
I'm just gonna do bonus videos feel free
to leave any requests you want but I
might do a character video next week bye
guys wait for that you can click here
for my easter egg from last week to
learn all about the dollmaker and all
that stuff that I just explained and you
can click here to catch up with arrow in
the flash which is also on break right
now thank you so much watching so let's
all high-five I'll see you guys tomorrow
you